com
ils se regardent tous les ans les autres
avec une attention particulière car il
faut savoir cerner son adversaire voire
qui l'on a en face de soi pour prétendre
faire mieux à la clé la première marche
du podium
alors pas question de se rater
au fil des minutes les musiques
s'enchaînent les performances
surprennent les dj change les juges
notent et le public apprécie
[Musique]
mais se dit pourquoi pas voilées dit
cammas est en effet sous les 1 fois j'ai
donc voilà pour le moment c'est bien on
s'amuserait puis ça s'appelle fois ça a
changé même si parfois ce qu'elles ont
conduit à préférer pour le
choix difficile pourquoi la joie des
films
j'aime bien comme quoi par exemple
le concours de dj amateur de la ville de
trinité réunis sur celle-ci jeune dj au
delà de le remporter
le but est avant tout de se faire
connaître il y a trois ans dj lycée
lancer dans l'aventuré des mix des
scratchs et autres transitions bref
c'est tout l'univers dj qui me plaît
j'aime énormément la musique que ce
soient les groupes de carnaval dans
lesquelles j'ai déjà joint au site et le
1156 la musique en général qui m'a
appris aussi un mètre derrière les
platines originalité rapidité créativité
maîtrise des sont autant de critères que
les candidats doivent maîtriser juriez
parrain de l'événement bon nous craindre
pendant professionnel en demande passage
de pouvoir aussi à la nouvelle
génération veut montrer aux jeunes qu'on
est là pour eux qu'on s'applique on est
à l'écouté un bon temps et après une
heure de bataille sur des platines
didier this may remporte le premier prix
sa rapidité et les transitions maîtriser
nouveau fait la différence dans ma
rapidité toujours parce qu'on ne cesse
jamais de sa milice a le truc
donc je continue toujours de performer
comics on va partager un bon lavage
cette cinquième édition du concours de
dj amateur organisé par la ville de
trinité a pour objectif de mettre en
avant tous ces jeunes talents
une soirée qui s'est terminée
bonjour en musique
[Musique]